und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
hallo und guten abend hinein wer aktuell
nicht sowieso schon urlaubsreif ist wird
spätestens beim flug in die ferien so
weit sein die deutsche lufthansa bietet
ihren passagieren ja schon seit längerem
enorm viel zu heute kommt ein streik
ihres bodenpersonals dazu der die
airline an den knotenpunkten frankfurt
und münchen komplett lahmgelegt hat
management und gewerkschaft verdi
schieben sich gegenseitig die schuld zu
die stimmung im unternehmen ist mies
ausbaden müssen ist die fluggäste so
soll am sonntag berichtet so sieht es
aus wenn der arbeitgeber mit verdi einen
tarifabschluss erreicht über 18 prozent
mehr für das bodenpersonal überwiegend
reibungsloser ablauf in stuttgart und so
wenn es keine einigung gibt wie zwischen
lufthansa und verdi lufthansa streicht
allein am größten deutschen flughafen in
frankfurt fast 700 flüge und die meisten
hier hatten kein glück nach langem
warten vor den umbuchungsschalter prinz
aktuell habe ich verständnis
die rahmenbedingungen sind natürlich
schlecht aber für diejenigen die jetzt
gestrandet sind hier und lange warten
das ist natürlich bitter jetzt noch mal
möglich ist in urlaub zu fliegen wer
weiß wie es in zukunft ist und das ist
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt meiner
meinung nach insgesamt sind mehr als 130
tausend passagiere bundesweit vom streik
des bodenpersonals betroffen verdi
streikt in den laufenden
tarifverhandlungen am vormittag machten
die beschäftigten ihrem ärger vor der
lufthansa zentrale luft
die gewerkschaft fordert für das
bodenpersonal 9,5 prozent mehr lohn
mindestens aber 300 50 euro mehr im
monat und einen mindestlohn von 13 euro
pro stunde den bietet auch lufthansa
zusätzlich 250 euro mehr im monat und
weitere 2 prozent gehaltssteigerungen ab
2023 aber nur bei positiven
geschäftszahlen die beschäftigten kommen
aus einer zeit der korona pandemie wo
die lufthansa 31 prozent der
beschäftigten am boden abgebaut hat
obwohl sie mit steuermilliarden gerettet
wurde das angebot der lufthansa ist
nicht ausreichend an zwei stellen weil
es zum einen zu niedrig ist und zum
anderen gekoppelt an die
unternehmensentwicklung
lufthansa dagegen ist überzeugt ein
substanzielles angebot vorgelegt zu
haben was viel wert auf soziale
ausgewogenheit gelegt hat so dass gerade
kleine mittlere einkommen besonders
starke gehaltssteigerung sehen können
wir haben daher nicht das geringste
verständnis für einen solchen für mich
nicht mehr warnstreik zu nennenden
streikbewegung bis zu den nächsten
tarifverhandlungen am dritten august
werde es keine streiks geben so verdi
heute danach hänge es vom neuen angebot
der lufthansa ab
134 1000 passagiere mussten ihre pläne
heute ändern oder ganz absagen viele
umsteiger sind im terminal gestrandet
vielleicht noch tage lang da ist auch
viel vertrauen kaputtgegangen und peter
wagner am frankfurter flughafen was kann
denn noch kommen in den nächsten tagen
und wochen
ja also morgen sollte der normale
flugplan auf jeden fall wieder
funktionieren aber der ist ja bereits
reduziert wegen der personalengpässe bei
der airline und auch bei den flughäfen
am boden also nicht wenige passagiere
werden nicht sofort dorthin kommen wohin
sie eigentlich wollten denn der druck im
weltweiten system luftfahrt er bleibt
weiterhin enorm und nächste woche gehen
die verhandlungen mit verdi dann weiter
lufthansa ist gewarnt durch diesen
harten warnstreik heute und so weit
liegen die position ja nicht auseinander
viel schwieriger dürfte es mit den
piloten werden die haben zur
urabstimmung aufgerufen am sonntag kommt
das ergebnis und zwischen piloten und
lufthansa ist das verhältnis ja schon
länger ziemlich angespannt und es geht
in deren in diesem anderen tarifstreit
nicht nur ums geld sondern um einige
grundsätzliche fragen in den vielen
tochtergesellschaften im konzern die
lufthansa muss jetzt schnell für ruhe im
gesamten unternehmen sorgen sonst geht
das auf kosten ihrer bilanz und vor
allem auch auf kosten vieler millionen
urlauber die ja dringend auf die viele
angewiesen sind jeder wagen nach live
aus frankfurt herzlichen dank
zwischen deutschland und der ukraine
zeichnet sich der bisher mit abstand
größte waffendeal ab nach vielen
unklarheiten nach kritik
missverständnissen und widersprüchen es
geht um die supermodernen
panzerhaubitzen 2000 die das standard
geschützt der deutschen artillerie sind
von ihnen sollen jetzt gleich 100
produziert werden dürfen das heißt
allerdings schnell gehen mit einem
einsatz in der ukraine wird es nicht
aber es kommt bei den deutschen
waffenlieferungen einiges in bewegung
thomas reichhardt und simon bärsch jetzt
mit mehr
an der front in der ukraine sind sie vor
angriffen gut versteckt die zehn
panzerhaubitzen die deutschland in den
letzten wochen aus bundeswehrbeständen
geliefert hat nun sollen weitere aus der
industrie hin zu kommen das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat schon
mitte juli dem rüstungsunternehmen
krauss maffei wegmann die herstellungs-
genehmigung für 100 panzerhaubitzen
erteilt das bestätigte kann wie dem zdf
der haubitzen dealgeld das geheimwissen
kmw sprecher heute vormittag zunächst
nur den export einer anderen schweren
waffen von gebhard flugabwehrkanonen
panzern bestätigte ich kann ihnen sagen
dass die bundesregierung den export von
30 g panzern genehmigt hat dieser export
hat begonnen darüber hinausgehende
details zu der zusammenarbeit mit der
ukraine sind in der information so
sensibel dass ich sie ihnen hier nicht
öffentlich ausbreiten möchte nun ist es
öffentlich man bereitet die produktion
der panzerhaubitzen vor so kmw insgesamt
geht es um kosten von rund 1,7
milliarden euro zukommen insgesamt 30
gebhard panzer die ukraine bekommt mit
dem flugabwehrkanonen panzer gibt ein
system das zum besten gehört was einher
bekommen kann wenn es sich durchsetzen
will gegen angriffe von tief fliegenden
flugzeugen
verteidigungsministerin land bricht
erklärt außerdem gestern über twitter
dass auch mehrfach raketenwerfer in die
ukraine geliefert wurden neben haubitzen
der bundeswehr wir halten wort so
lamprecht es ist ein einschnitt für eine
regierung die besonders wegen des
zögerns im kanzleramt zunimmt unter
druck geriet die bundeswehr kann selbst
kaum etwas abgeben deshalb die freigabe
für die industrie auch das
flugabwehrsystem die rst soll in die
ukraine gehen nach den informationen die
ich jetzt habe wird die industrie in der
lage sein das system bis ende des jahres
an die ukraine zu liefern weitere
panzerhaubitzen des werden der ukraine
erst mittelfristig helfen die produktion
kann zwei bis drei jahre dauern
und wir bleiben noch im moment in der
ukraine jetzt mit diana um den export
von millionen tonnen von getreide zu
ermöglichen die aktuelle in der ukraine
feststecken es heute ein kontrollzentrum
in istanbul eröffnet worden als teil des
getreide deals zwischen russland und der
ukraine soll das gemeinsame zentrum
handelsschiffe kontrollieren und ihre
durchfahrten durch den bosporus
ermöglichen so soll zum beispiel
waffenschmuggel verhindert werden
die bundesregierung hat eine anhebung
der krankenkassenbeiträge auf rekordhöhe
beschlossen laut gesetzentwurf soll der
zusatzbeitrag ab 2023 um 0,3
prozentpunkte auf 1,6 prozent des
bruttolohns steigen
das soll dabei helfen ein
milliardendefizit der gesetzlichen
krankenkassen auszugleichen
auch die pharmaindustrie soll zur kasse
gebeten werden geplant ist dass sie den
herstellerrabatt auf bestimmte
medikamente erhöht die amerikanische
notenbank fed hat den leitzins erneut
kräftig angehoben um 0,75 prozentpunkte
damit liegt er nun in der spanne von
2,25 bis 25 prozent die zentralbank
kündigte außerdem weitere zinserhöhungen
an auf diesem weg will die fed der hohen
inflation etwas entgegen setzen diese
lag in den usa zuletzt bei 9,1 prozent
die tunesier haben für eine neue und
hoch umstrittene verfassung gestimmt
diese schwächt die demokratie im land
und stärkt die rechte von präsident seit
so kann er künftig ohne
parlamentszustimmung die regierung
ernennen oder entlassen laut dem
vorläufigen ergebnis stimmten fast 95
prozent der wähler dafür
allerdings nahmen nicht einmal ein
drittel der wahlberechtigten an dem
referendum teil der opposition hatte zu
einem boykott der abstimmung aufgerufen
die waldbrände im süden brandenburgs und
in sachsen sind mittlerweile unter
kontrolle die lage bleibt aber
angespannt
in der sächsischen schweiz seien
einzelne brandherde eingedämmt und
stabilisiert worden andere würden sich
allerdings weiter ausbreiten erklärte
das dortige landratsamt
brandenburg hat der einsatz von
löschhubschraubern geholfen das feuer
unter kontrolle zu bringen
zu den wetteraussichten
morgen im osten und südwesten oft sonne
sonst mehr wolken am nachmittag südlich
der donau aufkommende gewitter 19 bis 31
grad in den nächsten tagen eine mischung
aus sonne wolken und einzelnen teils
kräftigen schauern und gewittern
höchstwerte 20 bis 31 grad
und das war es hier von uns in aller
kürze in jetzt weiterhin viel spass am
fussball 1
[Musik]